at eth zurich and he
um works with martin vetchev
and he wrote this really cool paper
recently uh
titled dl2 training and acquiring neural
networks with logic
which caught my eye and uh many other
people as well
in the broader context of verification
testing and analysis of neural networks
so i would in fact let mark explain his
work so without further ado mark please
go ahead
thank you also thank you pedro and vivek
for the wonderful talks and i feel
very much honored to be in such a
illustrious
company today so let me get started
so um i'm presenting deal two
training incurring neural networks with
logic so
this talk will mainly focus on two
recent papers well the tl2 paper from
icml 2019
and the learning certified individually
fair representations from
europe's 20 uh 2020 and both papers
would not have been possible without the
collaborators who are
misloved anna t monsi uh anjan and my
supervisor martin
now let's get started so
as it was already said um we have a
background in security and
and at this robustness also so our
first intuition was we want to
understand what the neural network
actually does
so the very first example that we looked
at was actually we have some neural
network
that takes a description of a person in
some tabular data
and decides whether the person is
approved for a loan or not and we wanted
to understand
okay if the person is not approved what
is the minimal change they can make to
this person
or to the description of this person
such that the loan would get approved
well and as i mentioned we have a
background in additional robustness
so we said okay let's let's not just
look at tabular data let's also look
at images which in which it's so they're
the context in which
this robustness is commonly studied so
as a recap if you're not familiar with
additional robustness
soon after neural networks started
really taking off for image
classification
uh several researchers found that they
are very sensitive to
particular particularly crafted noise
so if you give a neural network this
image of a panda it will classify as
panda this concrete neural network here
has a okay confidence for this statement
now if you add the specially crafted
noise you as a human don't see really a
difference between the two images
but for the neural network it's now a
given and it's a given with very high
certainty
now keeping this in mind we decided to
look
at several queries similar to that one
so you wanted to understand if you have
two real networks trained for the same
task but they maybe differ
in the data that was used the loss
function was used the architectures used
or just
the noise of the training procedure then
can we understand
where and how these neural networks
differ so can we find an input such that
they produce different outputs or can we
find an input
similar to a given input such they
produce different objects and the
similar
actually means similar as in here
so human wouldn't see a difference also
can we find
inputs that deactivate certain neurons
that should be active
if you look at other cat inputs for
example can we
use can we also find the visual examples
i mean we've shown it or can we find the
digital examples
by using also an additional neural
network so
um here we have a generator network that
takes some
noise vector and a class and produces a
image for for the given class now can we
find the noise such that we produce an
image of a cat but that rules that other
neural network into thinking it's a dog
and as you can see by dissertations
these are problems that other people
have looked in
individually so
well what we did in the still to work
here is we introduce
for querying we introduce a domain
specific language
that allows us to trace all of them and
many more in this sql-like
language and that way we can easily test
this
property or test these properties for
neural networks
now in this talk and this is the
connection to logic actually i want to
talk about how we solve these queries
once we have them
so for this we have a pipeline we take
the query we translate it into a logical
formula
then based on this logic formula we
define a differential loss
and this loss has two nice properties
the way we define it it is always
non-negative
so it's either a positive value or zero
and if it is zero we know that we have a
uh does we have a satisfying assignment
for the formula so that we have a
satisfied formula essentially
um so even these two properties we can
then just minimize the loss and if we
hit zero we are lucky that we have a
satisfying assignment or initial query
now how do we so how do we do individual
parts of this work well first let's look
at the translation
of the query to logic to this end let's
take a closer look at this example again
this is an example that i talked about
before where we look for a noise vector
so in particular this noise vector here
is 100 dimensional so this is some real
valued or float valued vector with
hundred dimensions
and we also know that these values are
usually minus one
minus one one so this constraint tells
us all dimensions of this hundred
dimensional vector
are between minus one and one then we
just apply the
neural network channel as a generator to
this uh
to this noise and some constant for cut
and then we apply the neural network and
then we have some synthetic sugar to
ensure that the classification will be
dark
so that's the language and this is this
example query that we'll use now
and now we translate this to logic well
what kind of logic well we use a very
restricted but
for a subset of formal first order logic
which focuses on
numerical comparisons so really
we allow numerical variables here
we allow some numerical constants like
the minus one or the cat
they're all constants and we allow
numerical functions such as the neural
networks so
gen here or and then for the classified
that we've just seen
and then we allow comparisons to mostly
less so standard numerical comparisons
over them
and on top of these terms we then allow
the standard logical operators so
conjunction disjunction negation
and now if we take um
if i can look at this query uh let's
look at so the actual constraint is in
green
and this is what we would then translate
to to logic
so let me quickly move out of the
let me move the windows from zoom out of
the way because i don't see my slide
okay so if you take a look at this minus
one to one constraint we say we have a
hundred dimensional variable
and we say all of the dimensions are
between minus one and one and this is
essentially what is say in the formula
so it's quite straightforward for the
classification constraint with the same
so again uh quickly recap neural network
so if you have classification of the
neural network
if you have k classes then given an
input the neural network usually outputs
k
numbers the so-called logits one
associated with each class
and we usually say that the logic of the
largest class is the winner
so it gets classified to whatever that
log it represents
and now in this formula here we'll also
say all so we want classification to be
docked so all logics are
smaller than the dollar logic and that's
what we say logic
so since i am a grad student myself in
our case this is really an automated
process to translate this so this is
standard
we parse the language and then have some
translation of the facts and logical
formula
now more interestingly what do we do
once we have the logical formula
so how do we get this translation and
what do we do with it
so to this end we introduce a recursive
translation operator
and since our language is much
is focused on these numerical
comparisons we didn't stay with
the standard tnorm setting that vivek
mentioned before
we've recommended before we we rather
have a custom translation
that's also invited by another work that
will mention in in a second
um and this gives us these key
properties
so this loss is always non-negative and
this loss is serious and only if it's
satisfied
so the key of the translation is really
this hinge loss here so if you have a
comparison between two numbers t1 and t2
so if t1 is less than d2 then we
translate this as
the formula here so
if d1 is less than t2 this is zero else
this is larger and just by construction
we can see that these two properties
hold
now similarly if we look at addition
here in addition
logically require addition is true if
both if both individual
sub formulas are true so to get the
trans the loss translation of this joint
conjunction we need both sides to be
true
so in our translation true means uh it
maps to zero
so addition perfectly captures the
semantics of um
of conjunction um
yes so this translation is nice because
it allows
uh differentiability of the loss that we
obtain with respect to the
variables so the variables that we are
looking for
uh so in the previous example the noise
i
also it's differentiable with respect to
the weights of the neural network
now mathematically speaking it's only
differentiable almost everywhere because
this
uh hinge loss translation here is not
differentiable at zero and also
if you have a neural network they're
usually also only differentiable at
all differentiably almost everywhere
because they also include these maximum
terms as values
uh but practically speaking
differentiably on
differentiability almost everywhere
works fine for us
so to take again a look at this example
that we had before
so if you have this constraint here for
minor for the minus one to one range
this just gets applying this first and
the last rule here
gets just translated into the sum of
hinge losses and that's it
so this is quite straightforward and we
found just to work relatively well
i will come back to motivation for this
work and and a few problems with this
later but now we have we have a loss
great so now we just need to minimize it
as i said
the loss is differentiable with respect
to the input so we can just use gradient
methods
so you can do standard grade in the
sentiment however there's two problems
um we are not convicts so this is
one due to the translation of this
junction which uses multiplication
and we end the new network itself so if
you encode your
net neural network in this formula it is
also not convex
so this non-convexity means you you're
not guaranteed to find the global
minimum
if uh if there is one if you just apply
gradient method
so in practice we can use what the color
methods sample multiple starting points
to perform great and
descend from them further you can also
employ
specialized specialized optimizers to
speed this up further
so if you go back to this example here
we are optimizing um for an i in the
reals so 100 dimensional reals or floats
in implementation
and we have this constraint here that
should ensure that it's always between
-1 and 1
in all dimensions but if you're familiar
with optimization there's actually a
large class of optimizers that can
handle such constraints directly so this
is called the box constraint as it boxes
in
this variable that we're optimizing and
one of them is for example lbgsb
the minus b for box constraint so
essentially what we do in this
translation phase here
is we just remove this con set
constraint and add it to the optimizer
so
rather than optimizing for an i in the
100 dimensional reals we're now
optimizing for an i
in the interval minus one to one to the
100 and we can remove this term from the
block from the loss here
so while these calls to this lpgsb
optimizer are more expensive than
standard grade in the sense this is a
quasi-nude method
it estimates
additional information rather than just
a gradient
the overall optimization procedure with
this is cheaper
and usually concurs faster so
this is our curing procedure uh now
let's see how
compares to other works so
essentially what we're doing once we're
given a query we translate it into
um into a logical formula and then we
look for a satisfying assignment to the
logical formula
so if you're familiar with smt solvers
they would be the standard tool for for
a job like this
so you have a formula look for a
satisfying assignment you're done
so what's the issue well let's let's uh
take a closer look
so as we all know some t-servers are
usually sound and complete
sound means they just return correct
solutions and complete means
if there is a resolution they will
return it
termination with standing but if it
terminates in reasonable time because we
know that if on the solution or
um again termination with not respecting
this allows us to compute whether
formula is unsatisfiable if we can't
find the solution
and uh even though modern uh
cmt solvers like step three or many
other works
are very very scalable in terms of mt
solving
they are still not scalable enough to
encode a full
neural network state-of-the-art neural
network or multiple of them in order to
answer the queries that we are looking
at
so to alleviate the scalability issue
there's actually
a work called accept by funsu from 2016
which performs a very similar similar
trick to our work
where they replace this dpl decision
procedure
by optimization so similar to us they
have a translation from the logical
formula into numerical loss
on which they can then apply numerical
optimization
and they have a similar property
property if they reach zero they have a
satisfying assignment
and this allows them to be much more
scalable than standard smt solders
however for our fire context they are
still not
scalable enough for neural networks also
the scalability came at the cost of
completeness so
this approach might miss some solutions
well we built on this approach so we
share this lack of completeness
however we specifically allow
optimization gradient methods since our
loss is differentiable
so we can use the standard frameworks
for neural networks to build
one and thus scale to much larger neural
networks and kind of answer queries
about them
so now this essentially concludes the
part about
uh querying the neural network so since
we now have this logic to loss
translation
we ask ourselves can we use it to uh
also train your networks
and we mentioned a very similar similar
direction as uh spivak in uh suggests in
his talk
so can we train a neural network such
that some logical formula holds for it
so can we include q
include some variants for example in the
neural network
well let's take a look so our goal is we
have some formula 5
and it might be over the weights of the
neural network or that might be over
some inputs
output or some input at least or input
output pairs
and we want this to hold for all inputs
essentially well
it will likely never hold fall inputs
but that's our goal
so we want to train a neural network to
do this well commonly when you train a
neural network
you find weights such to minimize some
expected loss
over the data set and usually here you
would have some classification loss
in standard image classification for
example
well in our case we can just use our
last translation of this formula phi now
plug in the current data and the weights
of the neural network the weights are
denoted
it's blue theta here and the x is the
current data
and just perform gradient descent and
that already works well
however conceptually if you think about
it
from which data points we can learn the
most those are usually
the ones for which this formula 5
is currently not set not not fulfilled
or which are very close to not
fulfilling it
i mean logic doesn't really have a
notion of almost fulfilled
but if you translate it to the numeric
numerical losses we have
then you can say oh this is very close
to being fulfilled or very close to not
being fulfilled
so these are the points from which we
can learn the most and these are denoted
as
counter example c so how do we find
these counter examples
well i've just spoken about how we can
query the neural network with logic
so using the same translation we can
just create the neural network
for the negation of this formula not phi
find the
ideally find a solution to this not phi
formula
and then plug them in as counter
examples however as i
just hinted we don't need to find a real
counter example here but
just optimizing this direction of
not phi essentially already gives us a
data point on which we can learn much
more
as i hint at the beginning we have a
background in mostly
or background in at the same robustness
and how to make neural networks
robust and by robust we mean how can we
avoid
such uh how can we avoid such
counterexamples as
uh as these visual examples that i've
shown well the standard way is actually
to
or the best way to do this is actually
to train on the counter examples
themselves
so the standard training loss looks uh
now looks like this
so we still are minimizing uh some as
unexpected loss and we are optimizing
the weights to do so
but and now we again have a loss
over the data and the label but now
we also have this maximization here and
we say s is the set
of allowed perturbations or considered
perturbations
and now we are looking for the worst
case perturbation in this set so the one
that maximizes the loss the most
and this overall is a very challenging
optimization problem it's a common
solute especially if you want to degrade
in descent and want this inner loop to
be fast
so a common approach is to approximate
this in a in a loop by
a iterative feature um commonly known as
pgd projected gradient descent
where you can take your current start
point go a bit into the direction of the
loss
and then after you took this step in the
direction of the loss gradient
you might be outside this set of allowed
perturbations so
we say x s here for the set of allowed
perturbations around the input x
so we just project back to this
and this is so this is known as ptd or
project green descent especially
in the context of hcl training but if
you have a background in optimization
this is the same
project the gradient descent algorithm
from there just instantiated this common
problem
now if you look at this you can see that
this is conceptually quite similar
so we perform the same we update the
neural network then we look for worst
case counter examples then we update the
neural network
so actually we generalize this
additional robustness training procedure
to logical formulas essentially
and if you pick a correct logical
formula then you can actually
get very close to this procedure here
back here
and you can apply this um to different
data modalities so supervised training
if you have both the data and the label
or just uh unsupervised the
semi-supervised if your label is missing
for some of the data
and another another nice thing that we
can take from
adostil robustness here is this idea of
projection
so if in this logical formula not phi
here we have some part
for which we have a closed form
numerical projection operator
we can do this so we take a step we can
use this to
speed up this training loop so we can go
a bit into a
gradient direction of this loss and then
uh project back so an example for this
would be this minus one to one
constraints that i mentioned earlier but
also all kinds of normals and lines
one drawback of this method is since we
are learning with gradient descent
we can't guarantee anything so in the
end phi
will hold in practice hold for many of
the inputs but not necessarily all
or well it will never we can never say
anything about all future inputs but
even for all the inputs that we have in
our data set it might not even hold for
all it will just hold for many of them
now
why is this interesting well
vivek already mentioned a few
use cases so incorporating domain
knowledge or using unlabeled data
as in his case but also it allows to you
and enforce safety constraints which is
the directions most interesting to us
so let me showcase this on a very small
toy example and then in
at the end of the talk we'll look at the
large example where we employ this
uh to show fairness
in you know individual fairness between
users and neural networks
so here we have this example a car
should be considered more similar to a
drug than a dog
which is something you can get on board
with i assume
it's a toy example but but it should
hold generally
and here we just have some constraint
that the input should look like an image
so for all things that looks like an
image and where the
uh where an original stop and that they
show a car
the log it for truck should be larger
than the luggage for dock
plus some delta so it's a very easy
formula
but if you do not to any special
training
it only holds for half the points in the
data set now
if you perform this training procedure
that's just mentioned it now holds for
virtually all
not all but virtually all data points
however this comes at a slight cost in
standard prediction accuracy
so this is some image classification
task and uh
it's a slight drop in prediction
accuracy but it allows to enforce this
constraint accuracy
now so far i've shown you this querying
and this training approach and both rely
on this logical loss translation now
before i show you the concluding example
i want to talk a bit about the open
problems with this
again very similar to what vivek
mentioned we
are still looking at what is the optimal
logic loss translation
translation essentially so for example
there is in fact infinitely many
translations similar to the one that
i've
that i've shown that has this property
that it's non-negative and
negative if the formula is satisfied
however they have different
uh with different numerical optimization
properties
so we ain't we're interested in
theoretical understanding
of which properties you you would want
and which therefore which translations
and
also in the engineering approach tells
us which are the best translation for
the given input
further we are we're still looking to
make this training procedure here more
efficient
for example by employing more of these
projection operators that i've mentioned
earlier
and also to allow a kind of hard
enforcement at least for
for parts of the rule so you have a
small set of your data set for which
you want to be sure that this rule is
hard enforced um
again this is relevant to context safety
constraints for example
now since i've shown you the mother
framework side of this i want to talk
about one application
and this application is individual
fairness
so individual fairness just says similar
individuals should be treated similarly
well as we are again talking about the
classification setting treated similarly
just means classified the same
what are similar individuals well i'll
come to that in a moment i
just wanted to fully motivate the
setting before so
here we follow an approach on fair
representation learning from
mcnamara and the idea is that we have
three parties a data regulator a data
producer and a data consumer
the data regulator is some let's say
government agency
that defines the fairness notion for a
task and now the data produces and the
data consumer to companies
that want to comply to this fairness
notion
so we can think of them as let's say to
banks or insurances
and the data producer has a large
database of user data
and the data consumer has a uh wants to
use this
information for some downstream
classification tasks
now uh they need to comply to the
circuit uh
regular fairness regularization fairness
tasks set by the regulator
and they need to ensure this and ideally
they don't want to share
data between the producer the consumer
so how did you do this well first let's
talk about how the regulator defines
which individuals are similar
to motivators in this logic setting we
say to individuals x and x prime are
similar
if some logical formula over them is
true in particular we are now back in
this tabular data setting from the
beginning where we have individuals and
they are comprised of
their described by categorical and
numerical attributes so
and the formula just says we want all of
the categorical attributes other than
gender to be the same
and all of the numerical attributes to
be at least in some range of each other
so if you look at individuals one and
two they're both engineers so that's the
categorical one
check they both have similar income so
let's say the
income the alpha is sufficient to uh
count them a similar and the gender is
different but we don't count that one
so at least for the shown attributes
individuals one and two are similar but
individual three would be different
so now how can we use uh the logic train
training with logic approach to ensure
this well
um we have the data produced in the data
consumer both training neural network
the data producer trains the neural
network f
and the consumer and network h this new
network
f of the data producer takes an input
so one of the decryptions of the
individual and maps them to
to a latent space then the data consumer
can take this latent space
and classify the individual from there
now
what we really want to enforce is this
property from the beginning
the so it's the property that two
similar individuals so if the formula
five holds
they get mapped close together in this
latent space here
and for this we use the training
procedure i just introduced
and if you look at this visualization
here so this is the input x
and this brown region is all of the x
primes for which this formula holds
now if you feed this through the neural
network then
we end up with this other brown region
now as i said before
since the training only holds for most
points but not necessarily all
we still can't verify anything at uh
inference time so we can't guarantee
anything
so to this end what we want to show at
inference time is
that for all x prime uh this formula
holds but there might be some
epsilon now rather than the delta from
above
why is the different epsilon well as i
said so in most cases this epsilon will
be close to the delta but as the
training might not always be
always hold we sometimes might obtain a
large epsilon
in practice we actually find this bank
holding this formula as a
and the whole new network as a mixed
integer linear program and then solving
for this epsilon
so once we have after so that way we end
up with this orange box
so if you take this brown set here map
it through the neural network then we
end up with this brown set again
and here we over approximate this with
the brown set now if we take this bronze
set
so this bronze set is parameters by the
center point c and this
uh radius in the lymphedenor epsilon
essentially and once we have this we can
give it to the data consumer
who can just prove to us that all of
these points certified the same
yes this is on my last slide okay
so that way we can show that all of them
classify the same and thus we've proven
the property
and this is enabled by training with our
boss
so now to summarize i've shown you the
dl2 approach uh
where we have training and querying and
then i've shown this application in
individual fairness
and i'm sorry for going over time but if
there are questions i'm still happy to
take them
thank you very much mark for a very nice
talk uh one
quick question how do you define optimal
counter example that z
star um
what do you mean by that so
if we so if we assume that the formula
not phi is satisfiable
not if the not fi satisfiable
then just by by construction our
translation must have a point where it
is zero
so um this might be a formula involving
x and the weights of the neural network
and there is the set somewhere
that there's this c somewhere in the in
the formula
and this is a variable and
we cannot we can try to find a
assignment for this variable
such that this formula is true meaning
the
overall loss is zero and there are cases
where we find this
and then this is the c star however
just due to the gradient optimization we
might not find one or the
formula might actually sometimes not be
satisfiable
then we won't find one but the grading
extent will still give us one that
numerically
minimizes this l and this would be the c
star then
thank you very much uh vinil can you
please share your screen
thank you again mark for your very nice
talk welcome
so the next talk is by vanilla nagiseti
uh
he's going to talk about an algorithm
called constrained gradient descent to
test
neural network